episode 4 of hawkeye has landed and the
series is proving yet again that it can
bring the drama and the fun on a much
smaller scale than big budget mcu
properties the show is doing a fantastic
job of building the relationship between
clint and kate who had some very high
highs and very low lows this week this
week's installment was all about clint
and kate's partnership which the former
eventually seems to surrender to after
three episodes of hesitation kate has
been pushing for their team status from
the get-go and things were finally
starting to go her way until the ending
that is the episode picks up with
eleanor and jack catching clint and kate
in the penthouse and the foursome sits
down and has a rather awkward chat after
admitting that he's working with kate
clint leaves and is warned by eleanor to
take it easy with her daughter since
tragedy seems to follow him after he
leaves she calls someone on the phone
and leaves a message saying she needs to
talk about something urgent who is she
talking to our guest is kingpin who did
not show up in this episode despite many
rumors suggesting he'd make an
appearance in a post-credit scene
eleanor's phone call is just another
tease at the looming threat and hawkeye
after three episodes worth of red
herrings the mention of uncle in episode
3 got the kingpin buzz going especially
after we saw a mystery man pinch young
echo's cheek the mystery phone call is
not to jack since he was in the
penthouse at the time and ekko and kazi
are both unlikely candidates this phone
call was probably for someone we haven't
seen yet in the show and all signs are
pointing to kingpin aka wilson fisk but
we are all impatiently waiting to see in
his broad shoulder glory
after he leaves kate's penthouse clint
makes a phone call to the most
understanding woman in the world to tell
her he's going to need another day laura
is as sympathetic to the cause as she's
always been but something different
about the couple's conversation is worth
a second look she's already been doing
some detective work for clint after he
texted her some info on sloane limited
after recovering his ronin sword and
laura seems to have some skills we've
never been privy to laura lets clint
know that jack is the ceo of sloan
limited and it only took her mere
minutes to come up with this information
how is she researching and getting
answers so quickly has she just picked
up research skills from her husband over
the years probably not and here's why
swapping english for german to confuse
her kids laura asked clint if anything
else went missing from the avengers
compound he immediately knows she's
talking about the rolex which we saw at
the auction in episode 1 and says he
thought it was destroyed years ago laura
agrees but then says she felt the same
way about the ronin suit clint decides
to look into it and we get the sense
that this rolex is connected to laura
somehow she seems very concerned that it
could be in the wrong hands and the
episode turns to a recovery mission of
the stolen watch signs suggest that
laura might have a secret history
especially after clint tells kate the
person connected to the watch has been
quote out of the game for a long time
was laura a former shield agent is that
how she met clint some fans on twitter
are suggesting laura is mockingbird
hawkeye's ex-wife but current girlfriend
from the comics it's a lot to unpack but
hopefully we'll get more on that in
future episodes when clint and kate's
mission turns toward the rolex they
track it to a mysterious apartment kate
gets herself inside and finds a watch
reasonably quickly but it's also sitting
next to a notebook with the names and
ages of clint's family on it in the
middle of the recovery clint deduces
that cade is in echo's apartment after
realizing the mysterious strobe lights
are a silent alarm
kate is then surprised by ekko and the
two begin to fight in the apartment
while clint is on the nearby rooftop
also being attacked by someone he thinks
is echo the foursome all end up together
on the rooftop and a well-choreographed
group fight ensues clint's assailant is
fully masked and remains a mystery to
him and us until the end we get this
sense he has an idea of who he's
fighting based on their attack style and
weapons used and the big reveal happens
just before the episode ends elena
belova last seen in black widow has made
her way to new york and seems hell-bent
on taking out clint as vengeance for the
death of natasha after her mask is off
she escapes by launching herself off the
building and has gone into the night
it's here that there is a rift in the
relationship between kate and clint as
he declares they are not partners and
never were clint informs kate that
someone has hired a black widow assassin
and he's going solo he's gotten very
real
very quickly
the appearance of a black widow has
brought out the grief in him yet again
and this debacle is now so much more
than squashing the ronin identity
however he does not appear to know that
this is elena did not even tell him
about her adoptive sister there are so
many unanswered questions but hopefully
we'll get some clarity in episode 5.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
hawkeye are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]